voit bien que de très nombreuses
entreprises on est en grande difficulté
le chômage va augmenter il ya beaucoup
de fautes de français qui vont souffrir
également sur le plan financier et donc
il faut penser à toutes ces pme c'était
pe toutes ces professions libérales qui
aujourd'hui sont au bord de la route et
qui vont souffrir
alors le gouvernement a mis en place un
certain nombre de dispositifs c'est
important mais ce n'est pas encore
suffisant il faut davantage de
précisions pour y avoir accès on voit
bien que les conditions d'accès il ya
embouteillage parce que tout le monde
essaie d'accéder par les moyens
numériques qu'il a à sa disposition et
qui sont inégaux suivant les endroits où
on ce trouble parce qu'il ya aussi des
zones blanches toujours dans ce pays
et c'est dans ces périodes qu'on se rend
compte de façon vraiment préoccupante
donc les assurances comme les
entreprises qui elles fonctionnent bien
doivent être mis à contribution il ya
des entreprises qui profitent de la
crise on voit bien et donc cette
inégalité il faut que ceux qui vont bien
ou ceux qui sont là pour protéger d'un
appel pour ceux qui vont mal mais ce
qu'il faut mettre également à
contribution les plus fortunés par
exemple gérald darmanin a fait un appel
aux dons une sorte de corona ton pour et
bien soutenir l'effort national je crois
pas que ce soit au niveau et à la
hauteur
je pense qu'il faut trouver des
solutions qui soient plus adaptée qui
soit plus en rapport avec ce qui est la
france je veux dire on a des sommes
importantes celles là sont épargnés
souvent elles ont une part de capital
national je pense à edf air france ou à
d'autres grandes entreprises
là c'est l'état qui devra massivement
intervenir pour les protéger en revanche
moi je pense surtout à toutes ces
petites entreprises celles qui
constituent le thème le tissu économique
de notre pays qui créent l'emploi et qui
demain vont être en grande difficulté et
non pas trésorerie et donc la première
chose à faire c'est non pas de reporter
mais d'annuler les charges qu'elles
doivent payer parce que elles n'ont pas
pu travailler en mars et n'ont pas pu
travailler vraisemblablement en avril
pourront difficilement travailler en mai
donc ce n'est pas en reportant les
charges qu'on va les aider il va falloir
à un moment donné annuler ses charges
parce que si on veut créer un appel
d'air si on veut les aider je verrai
fois les uns l'annulation et non pas au
report est pourquoi le gouvernement
refuse d'annuler tout de suite ses
charges
je pense que le gouvernement travaille à
l'évaluation parce qu'on a déjà dépend
beaucoup d'argent c'était nécessaire et
je pense qu'il faut savoir de quelle
évaluation parle de quelle date à quelle
date également de quel type d'entreprise
ça va être toute les entreprises encore
une fois les importantes elles sont
certainement aussi leurs difficultés
c'est pas du même niveau si mon public
avec quelques
salariés ou à ces pme qui sont dans les
villages et les villes de france et qui
souffrent aujourd'hui qui sont à l'arrêt
c'est une question sur les élus locaux
les élus locaux payent un lourd tribut
durant cette crise sanitaire
beaucoup de communes ont perdu leur mère
à cause du courant navires us beaucoup
d'élus ont disparu c'est dû à la
campagne municipale
c'est en tout cas dû au fait qu'ils sont
en première ligne parce que quand il ya
une crise comme celle là et on l'avait
vu une autre crise qui était celle des
gels et jaune ceux qui sont devant ceux
qui sont en première ligne
ce sont pour l'état les préfets et pour
le terrain les maires la vie française
c'est bien sûr l'armée la police la
gendarmerie mais c'est surtout les
maires et les préfets qui sont en
première ligne
les élus et aux contacts la population
ils sont toujours là la maison commune
ce soit une petite ville une grande
ville c'est vers les élus qu'on se
tourne
parce que c'est la proximité c'est eux
qui apportent des réponses ils paient le
tribut et je pense notamment à mon ami
patrick devedjian qui est décédé il ya
quelques jours